the royal navy's largest aircraft
carrier which sailed from portsmouth
yesterday following delays due to
technical problems has broken down off
the isle of wight divers are inspecting
hms at prince of wales with reports
suggesting there is damage to the
vessel's propeller shaft our
correspondent sergeant chowdhury is on
the isle of wight for us so have they
got it going again yet
yes uh it is on the move just over my
right shoulder moving quite fast it's
constantly moving over my left and right
shoulder but the royal navy says that it
is being moved now to a different
anchorage so that further inspections
can take place the vessel has been
somewhat stranded here on the south
coast for several hours having departed
from the portsmouth uh harbour just
yesterday um
just uh on saturday a beg your pardon
now there are we still don't know what's
wrong with it but there are different
things coming out so one is that the mod
has officially said that it is
an emerging mechanical issue but we've
also heard reports as you say of this
damage to the propeller shaft and a
short while ago we ran into a former
royal navy engineer who said that the
the bay here is quite narrow and about
45 years ago a different vessel hms
eagle also damaged its propeller shaft
trying to get out it's a very tight
tight turning to make a short while ago
we went out on a boat to get a closer
look we went about five miles off the
coast and we saw about six or seven
smaller much smaller vessels trying to
assist this one uh in trying to move so
it is on the move and we still don't
know what's wrong with it but it was on
its way to the united states for
training exercises it was going to spend
the next three months from going to new
york and to halifax and canada and also
the caribbean it perhaps is a little bit
embarrassing for the royal navy because
the hms prince of wales is one of its
most prized vessels but now it is in
need of repair